der neue klimaschutzminister Robert
Habeck stellt hier in Berlin seine
Eröffnungsbilanz vor sie zeigt wie sehr
Deutschland in Sachen Klimaschutz hinter
den Erwartungen liegt die Klimaziele
werden in diesem Jahr aller Voraussicht
nach verfehlt habe ich will nun mit
einem umfangreichen Maßnahmenpaket
nachbessern wie genau das aussehen soll
erfahren wir in wenigen Momenten live
hier bei Bild wir schauen mal auf das
live-signal aus der
Bundespressekonferenz meine Damen und
Herren da sehen wir es schon und wir
gehen direkt hinein
zu Robert Habeck der seine Pläne
vorstellt
[Musik]
und vielleicht letzten Mal ich ein
frohes neues Jahr ein Jahr das sieben
hoffentlich gute Gesundheit erhalten
bleibt dem Land ist ermöglicht durch die
verschiedenen Krisen die wir haben gut
durchzukommen und
[Musik]
auf konzentrierte und gute
Zusammenarbeit wir haben uns hier
eingeladen oder eingeladen lassen von
der Bundespressekonferenz um einmal mit
einem Schulterblick zu starten wo wir im
Bereich von Klimaschutz und
Energiepolitik stehen um vielleicht in
dieser Legislatur aus meiner Sicht
letztmalig zurückzuschauen und dann den
Blick beginnen mit diesem Tag und diesen
Woche komplett und konsequent nach vorne
zu richten aber einmal müssen wir den
Startpunkt noch definieren und schauen
wo wir stehen und
das wird jetzt nicht so sehr
überraschend nach der
Vorberichterstattung der letzten Tage
wir starten nicht auf der Ziellinie
sondern mit einem gehörigen Rückstand
wir müssen jetzt in den nächsten
Jahren
effizienter und schneller werden das
Tempo und die Konsequenz müssen zunehmen
im Prinzip kann man über den groben
Daumen sagen wir müssen dreimal besser
sein in allen Bereichen ich gehe gleich
noch mal auf die Schienen verschiedenen
Sektoren und sparten ein
mit den co2-missionen die ja die
Grundlage alles tun sind beginnen so
sehen wir dass die
Sondereffekte des Jahres 20 die es
ermöglicht haben im Jahr 2020 die
Zielmarke von -40% CO2-Emissionen
einzuhalten im Jahr 21 nicht gewirkt
haben und weg sind das heißt strukturell
sind wir deutlich schlechter als die
geplanten und vorher und und
vorgegebenen Ziele wir werden einen
Anstieg der Emissionen um 4%
wahrscheinlich haben so davon gehen die
Prognosen aus oder von 25 Millionen
Tonnen das heißt im Jahr 21 werden wir
die Emissionssenkung -40% deutlich
verfehlen
wenn wir den Pfad der bisherigen
Maßnahmen fortschreiben werden wir im
Jahr
2030 die Zielverfehlung noch deutlicher
sehen wir werden dann 15 Prozent unter
den vorher unter die minderungszielen
sein also nicht
-65% CO2-Emission sondern ungefähr minus
50% CO2-Emissionen das ist dann in
Zahlen ausgedrückt 200 Millionen Tonnen
zu viel und da wir dann noch ein Budget
von 400 Millionen Tonnen eigentlich
haben ist es 50 Prozent der Menge die
wir haben drüber ich habe das einmal
mitgebracht in einer Grafik dass man das
sehen kann wahrscheinlich von hinten
nicht aber da dass er übertragen wird
kann man es sich hier vielleicht ein
bisschen
dichter ranzoomen wir sehen hier das
Jahr 2020 das ist die corona-krise der
deutliche absackung des Balkens aber es
ist eben nicht politisch induziert oder
politisch getrieben und dann noch in der
Prognose die Zahl liegen noch nicht
wirklich fort aber dann sehen Sie hier
im Jahr 21 der Balken wieder nach oben
geht da sind wir also und da müssen wir
hin und wenn man das jetzt grob sieht
sieht man dass man die Minderung sagen
wir mal hier mit einem groben Daumen
hier sind wir gestartet der letzten
1990 also zwei Balken sind wir runter 4
müssen wir runter gehen in deutlich
kürzerer Zeit und den schwarzen Verlauf
den Sie hier sehen das sind die
minderungsergebnisse der bisher
beschlossenen politischen Maßnahmen und
wenn wir alles das umsetzen was im
Moment politisch vereinbart ist landen
wir hier und hier müssen wir sein und
hier hin zu kommen sie sehen also dass
die Aufgabe groß ist
gigantisch ist
wir haben in Zahlen im Jahr 2010 bis 20
die Emissionen Deutschland um 15
Millionen Tonnen senken können wir
müssen dann jährlich im Durchschnitt wir
müssen sie 2022 bis 30 um über 40
Millionen Tonnen senken das ist die der
Faktor 3 von dem ich gesprochen habe
jetzt schon bei den
emissionsssenkungen wir haben es
geschafft in Deutschland in den letzten
30 Jahren die erneuerbaren Energien zu
einem Anteil von 42 Prozent der
Stromversorgung zu bringen das ist eine
Leistung die man anerkennen muss
diejenigen die die Debatte länger
verfolgt haben können sich daran
erinnern dass zu Beginn des Ausbaus der
erneuerbaren gewarnt wurde dass mehr als
drei vier fünf Prozent Anteil der
Erneuerbaren das Stromsystem überhaupt
nicht verkraften könnte nun sind wir 30
Jahre später bei über 40 Prozent aber
wir haben dafür 30 Jahre gebraucht
und wir haben noch acht Jahre Zeit den
Anteil nach Planung der Bundesregierung
nach Koalitionsvertrag auf 80 Prozent zu
bringen also 30 Jahre gut 40 Prozent
acht Jahre um dann das Doppelte noch mal
zu machen dabei sind bisher in den
Berechnungen die steigenden strombedarfe
nicht eingepreist worden Deutschland
verbraucht ungefähr 560 Terawattstunden
Strom pro Jahr das wird aber steigen
durch holout der Wärmepumpen durch
Hochlauf der E-Mobilität wir werden dann
ungefähr bei 700 Terawattstunden
jährlich liegen die Schätzungen reichen
von 680 bis 750 also die 80% bezogen auf
den Strombedarf ist eben noch mal
bezogen auf eine größere Menge was die
Aufgabe nur noch größer macht bedrückend
ist dass der Trend in die falsche
Richtung geht wir haben über die letzten
drei Jahre ein Zubau von onshore Wind
das ist würde ich sagen noch immer der
Last Esel der erneuerbaren Energien von
einem Gigawatt
viel zu wenig offshore ist nahezu
komplett zum Erliegen gekommen
man sieht es hier beim Anteil der ich
habe es noch mal mitgebracht beim Anteil
der Erneuerbaren am Bruttostromverbrauch
das ist da wo wir sind sie sehen sogar
dass wir im letzten Jahr ein Zurückgehen
haben das wird man auch hinten erkennen
können hier geht es immer nicht steil
genug immer unbedingt aber es geht immer
bergauf so noch einmal geht es bergab in
einem Jahr wo wir eigentlich die
kehrtwände nun wirklich einleiten müssen
haben wir den Anteil am
Bruttostromverbrauch bei erneuerbaren
noch geringer und sie sehen wie steil
die Kurve dann nach oben gehen muss das
ist der Faktor 3 von dem ich gesprochen
habe
hier sehen Sie dann noch einmal in den
Grafiken das was ich gesagt habe den
Zubau von Wind und Photovoltaik das ist
der Zubau von Wind das dunkelblaue ist
offshore hier wurde offshore Rocky
zugebaut würde ich sagen dann ging es
runter und die letzten Jahre wurde
überhaupt nicht mehr auf Schritt
zugebaut und schon hier da ging es ganz
gut los und das sind die letzten Jahre
gewesen hier sind wir und das ist die
Prognose dessen was wir erreichen müssen
in den nächsten Jahren also sehen Sie
sich die Zahlen an das sind die Jahre
des maximalen Zubaus gewesen als es
richtig gut ging und sehen Sie sich an
was wir erreichen müssen bei
Photovoltaik ist die Tendenzen bisschen
besser sie sehen dass es bei den
niedrigen Jahren hier dann leicht
aufwärts gegangen ist aber gemessen an
dem was wir machen müssen ist selbst das
der okay Zubau würde ich sagen nur die
Startrampe hier müssen wir hin und das
kulminiert ist dann der Zubau der
erneuerbaren Energien über die nächsten
Jahre die wir leisten
um den Strombedarf und den Anteil den
wir dafür haben decken zu können
wenn wir uns anschauen woran es hapert
dann sind die Gründe vielfältig
vor allem ist bei offt bei on-shoa
festzustellen dass die Fläche einfach
schlichtweg nicht da ist um diese Mengen
zuzubauen brauchen wir zwei Prozent der
bundesdeutschen Fläche gute Nachricht
ist 98% der Fläche sind freizuhalten und
werden auch nicht gebraucht
ausgewiesen theoretisch sind 0,8 Prozent
faktisch zur Verfügung stehen 0,5 also
das was sie erleben ist ein Viertel
dessen was wir erkennen ein Viertel
dessen was wir tatsächlich brauchen
einige Flächen sind natürlich mit alten
Anlagen bestellt das sind auch häufig
die sehr windstarken Flächen das heißt
über das Repowering schonen wir die
Fläche und haben trotzdem einen guten
Zubau von Leistung aber wir brauchen
mehr Fläche völlig klar ich verzichte
jetzt heute hier darauf die Länder
einzeln durchzugehen bin aber mit den
Landesregierungen im Kontakt und suche
den Kontakt und wird die auch persönlich
besuchen um das dann einzeln
durchzusprechen aber es gibt nur zwei
Länder die in die Nähe des 2%-ziels
kommen das sind Hessen und
Schleswig-Holstein alle anderen liegen
darunter und da muss man jetzt nicht
lange um den heißen Brei herumliegen da
werden einige Gespräche zu führen sein
und das wird ein mühsamer Prozess werden
allerdings darf die mühsamkeit des
Prozesses nicht zu einer zeitlichen
Verzögerung führen wir müssen die
Flächen schaffen sonst kommen wir da
nicht dran und alle müssen mithelfen
dass wir diese Flächen schaffen wenn man
sich anschaut was weiterhin passieren
soll wenn man in die verschiedenen
Sektoren reingeht wir reden ja beim
Klimaschutz jetzt nicht mehr alleine vom
Strommarkt also dem Ausbau von
Photovoltaik und Wind sondern auch über
Industrie über Mobilität über Wärme so
ein paar Zahlen um zu verdeutlichen was
ansteht
alleine für den jährlichen Verbrauch der
Stahlindustrie wenn sie auf grünen Stahl
umgestellt werden 15 Terawattstunden
Wasserstoff 2030 benötigt drei
Terawattstunden Wasserstoff sind bisher
bundesweit für alle Sektoren in der
Planung und geplant also wir brauchen
ein massiven Hochlauf von Wasserstoff
wir wollen einen Rollout der Wärmepumpen
also stromgetrieben die dann aber dafür
sorgen dass die Wärmeversorgung
erneuerbar ist auf vier bis sechs
Millionen das ist eine verviertes für
6-fachung der bisherigen zahlen und
Planungen
wir haben beschlossen und das ist schon
ja auch berichtet worden den Hochlauf
der E-Mobilität auf 15 Millionen
Fahrzeuge 2030 das bedeutet dann aber
auch wenn der Konsequenz dass wir
jährlich 100.000 neue Ladepunkte
brauchen eine große infrastrukturaufgabe
die da auf uns zukommt
mir ist alles zusammen nehmen steht das
Land vor einer großen politischen
Debatte hier in der
Bundespressekonferenz kann man die
Zahlen referieren und die Grafiken
hochhalten und die Kameras klicken und
man sagt okay ganz schön sportliche
Aufgabe das wird mal interessant werden
wie das anzugehen ist wenn man dann im
Land unterwegs ist weiß man dass mit
diesen Zahlen nicht nur eine technische
Debatte verknüpft ist sondern eine
soziale Debatte eine Debatte die die
kulturelle Identität von Räumen betrifft
dazubau von erneuerbaren Energien macht
etwas mit dem ländlichen Raum eine
Debatte die das Verhältnis von Stadt als
großen Verbrauchszentren oder
Industriezentren und ländlichen Raum neu
betrifft eine Debatte die
Ost-West Nord-Süd in den verschiedenen
Kompetenzen und auch
debattenlagen und politischen Mehrheiten
betrifft also man muss sich keine
Illusionen darüber machen dass es eben
nicht nur eine technische Frage ist
sondern auch eine Frage ist die tief in
die gesellschaftliche Wirklichkeit
greift und nur dann gewonnen werden kann
wenn sie auch als gesellschaftliche
Debatte geführt werden wird ich
jedenfalls werde versuchen das so
aufzusetzen
[Musik]
um das Ganze in Gang zu bringen haben
wir uns ein ehrgeiziges Arbeitsprogramm
gesetzt wir planen zwei große
artikelgesetzspakete das eine ein eine
Art osterpaket im Frühjahr
soll die sofort wirksamen Maßnahmen
bündeln dann im Frühjahr um Ostern rum
durchs Kabinett so dass dann die
parlamentarischen befassungen bis zur
Sommerpause abgeschlossen sind einiges
von denen wird dann beihilfepflichtig
sein muss in Europa genehmigt werden
aber das was prioritäre Wirksamkeit
entfaltet muss alles in 2022 erledigt
sein damit es in 23 wirksam wird ich
gehe gleich noch mal ein bisschen durch
dann planen wir einen Sommerpaket wo
dann die weiteren prioritären Maßnahmen
die dann wirksam werden und die Flächen
die
Fördermöglichkeiten die neuen
gesetzlichen Normen darstellen dann in
der zweiten Jahreshälfte ebenfalls durch
das parlamentarische Verfahren bringt
also Oster und sommerp sind Begriffe für
die kabinettsbefassung die dann in den
Verfahren die nachgelagert sind
parlamentarische Befassung im Bundestag
gegebenenfalls in den Landesparlamenten
im Bundesrat oder Notifizierung in der
EU noch in 22 möglich machen
ein paar Bereiche kann man
identifizieren die jetzt dann sofort
angegangen werden müssen quasi mit
diesem Schulterblick des heutigen Tages
zurück dann blickt nach vorne das ist
die neue Aufstellung des EEG noch dann
im osterpaket mit der Erhöhung der
Ausschreibung entsprechend des 80% Ziels
wie eben in der Grafik vorgestellt mit
der Definition der überragenden
öffentlichen Bedeutung der erneuerbaren
Energien das ist ja das ist ein
Koalitionsvertrag noch mal
festgeschrieben wurde was ich aber
logisch ergibt wenn wir die erneuerbaren
Energien zum Rückgrat der
Energieversorgung machen dann sind sie
sicherheitsrelevant und müssen auch so
behandelt werden auch in der schutzgüte
Abwägung gegenüber anderen schutzgütern
und der Abschaffung der EEG-Umlage wir
werden zweitens einen
solarbeschleunigungspaket auf den Weg
bringen so dass
Dinge wie großzügigere Nutzung von
mieterstrom aber auch die solarpflicht
neue Flächen für Freiflächen PV und
bessere Fördersätze dort vereinbart
werden so dass wir zu einem Rollout der
PV der Solaranlagen in Deutschland noch
einmal kommen werden wir werden drittens
dann die Maßnahmen ergreifen die
genehmigte Flächen für Windkraftanlagen
hoffentlich schneller zu einer Bebauung
führen können wir haben in Deutschland
in der Summe acht bis neun Gigawatt
Gigawatt kann man sich merken ist im
Grunde ein Atomkraftwerk genehmigen in
der Kapazität genehmigte Flächen da
könnte also gebaut werden die aber
aufgrund von anderen
schutzgütern oder Gütern belegt sind das
sind vor allem Radaranlagen des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes oder der
Deutschen Flugsicherung für analoge
drehfunkfeuer also eine sehr alte
Technik die als Backup vorgehalten wird
und Flächen wo die Bundeswehr sagt dann
kann nicht gebaut werden aus
Sicherheitsüberlegungen die haben
natürlich alle in sich ihre mehr oder
weniger starke Berechtigung aber wir
müssen da vorankommen und ich bin mit
den Kollegen in gutem Gespräch und hoffe
dass wir kurzfristig dort Flächen
Freiräumen können so dass der Ausbau
dann wieder mindestens auf dem
genehmigten Flächen in Gang kommt da
sind wir noch gar nicht bei Artenschutz
und naturschutzrechtlichen Verfahren das
sind einfach nur Flächen die eigentlich
zur Verfügung stehen wo es eine
konkurrenzabwägung oder eine
Güterabwägung gibt die noch mal neu
vorzunehmen sein wird dann das Wind an
Landgesetz das wird sicherlich eine
kompliziertere Operation das ist das was
sich hinter dem zwei Prozent Ziel
verbirgt wir wollen mit dem osterpaket
die sogenannten contract carbontract for
diffances Verträge das sind die
förderverträge für die Industrie auf den
Weg bringen im Grunde der Logik nach
wenn jetzt die Industrie sich auf den
Weg macht in den verschiedenen Sparten
beispielsweise Wasserstoff einzusetzen
und die höhere Kosten hat gibt es einen
Vertrag mit der öffentlichen Hand diese
Mehrkosten zu erstatten wenn aber
beispielsweise durch einen höheren
CO2-Preis die neue Technik sich rechnet
also die Produktion auf einmal günstiger
wird zahlt wird ein Stück jedenfalls der
Fördermaßnahmen zurückgezahlt all das
soll programmiert werden das löst dann
die Bremse bei den Investitionen der
Industrie das schafft die Sicherheit für
die Investition und wird zu den
entsprechenden Umbaumaßnahmen in der
Industrie führen wir werden die
wärmestrategie auflegen die vor allem
über die kommunale wärmeplanung
dann dafür führen soll dass wir ab
2000 ab 2025 65 Prozent erneuerbare
Energie für alle neue Heizanlagen haben
werden dazu gehören auch Fördermaßnahmen
für die Fernwärmenetze also da wo es
Verbundsysteme geht kann man ja
gebündelt Energie rein führen wir setzen
vor allem darauf dass ein Förderprogramm
das gerade in der Notifizierung bei der
EU liegt das bew das Bundesprogramm für
effiziente wir haben jetzt einen großen
Effekt hat so dass wir auch
beispielsweise industrielle Abwärme
stärker in die Fernwärme Netzer
reinnehmen werden und über den Rollout
der Wärmepumpen habe ich schon
gesprochen
noch drei Punkte Gebäude
Energiegesetz neu aufzusetzen also die
Effizienzkriterien für Bauen und
Sanieren hochzusetzen gleichzeitig die
Förderung anzupassen und sowohl die
Sanierung wie auch die Versorgung mit
erneuerbaren Energien neu abzuwägen ist
Teil der Pakete die wasserstoffstrategie
muss neu aufgelegt werden in den drei
Bestandteilen Förderung Infrastruktur
und Beschaffung von
wasserstoffbeschaffung heißt sowohl
Importe von Wasserstoff die vereinbaren
zu vereinbaren sind wir aber auch
Standorte für
elektrolyseure zu identifizieren also da
wo große Mengen erneuerbarer Strom in
Deutschland verfügbar sind das sind
ideale Standorte um dann noch einmal
Wasserstoff in Deutschland in
erneuerbare Energien in Deutschland in
Wasserstoff umzuwandeln und
all das zusammen macht diese genannten
Oster und sommerpakete aus insgesamt mit
dem Blick zurück über die Schulter wo
wir stehen und den abfallenden Kurven
der Blick nach vorne es ist eine große
politische Aufgabe aber eine die
natürlich auch für das Land eine enorme
Chance bereithält und für die politische
Kultur eine enorme Chance bereithält
wenn wir sie bestehen diese Aufgabe wenn
wir das angehen werden wir darüber zu
einem neuen Verhältnis von Bund und Land
kommen also die föderale das föderale
zusammenspielt besser machen können wir
werden unsere Industrie erneuern und die
Industrie erneuern heißt eben auch
Wertschöpfung Arbeitsplätze
Wohlstand für Mittelstand und Handwerk
bereitstellen zu können wir werden
wieder
Innovationsland sein und wir werden
Bürokratie und
Planungsprozesse schlanker machen müssen
und können dadurch wir werden also
lernen können wir besser werden und was
gibt es für eine bessere Aufgabe
politisch zu verantworten zu lernen wie
man besser werden kann ich jedenfalls
und das Haus bei dem ich mich herzlich
bedanke dass es in sehr kurzer Zeit
diesen soliden Bericht der liegt Ihnen
jetzt ja vor 30 Seiten ungefähr was ich
hier in dürren Worten vorgestellt habe
tja lernen wie man besser werden kann
was kann es besseres geben Jan Schäfer
bei uns im Studio die erste Bilanz von
Robert Habeck dem Klimaschutz und
Wirtschaftsminister dein Eindruck also
das Programm was Robert Habeck jetzt
noch mal deutlicher skizziert hat ist
wirklich wahnsinnig ambitioniert er hat
ja am Anfang seiner Pressekonferenz
erklärt wo Deutschland derzeit steht
beispielsweise beim Thema erneuerbare
Energien hat gesagt dass im abgelaufenen
Jahr rund 42 Prozent des Stromes aus
erneuerbaren Energien stammt also
innerhalb von 30 Jahren ein Anteil von
42 Prozent und dann hat er gesagt diese
Anteil der muss einfach werden mehr als
verdoppelt eigentlich weil auch der
Energiehunger weiter steigen wird von
Deutschland verdoppelt werden und zwar
innerhalb von acht Jahren und das ist
sicherlich eine Herausforderung bei der
ich sagen würde das kann ich mir
eigentlich nicht vorstellen dass das
klappen kann denn das bedeutet unter
anderem das und das hat Robert Habeck
auch ausgeführt in diesem Land
wahnsinnig viele zum Beispiel neue
Windräder aufgestellt werden müssen wir
wissen dass es mit dem Aufstehen von
Windräder nicht ganz so einfach ist auch
die Zahl aus den letzten Jahren zeigen
dass es eher ein weniger großen Zuwachs
an wen hat das ganz gut verdeutlicht
indem er gesagt hat das was wir jetzt
haben sind 0,5% der Fläche 2% müssen wir
aber haben man kann sich also vorstellen
wie viele windmasten da zusätzlich dazu
kommen müssen genau da geht das Problem
los denn wir wissen auch so ein Windrad
das dann am Ende oder die Windräder die
2% der Fläche in Deutschland dann
besiedeln sollen das ist ja nicht ohne
Probleme auch vor Ort umzusetzen also er
hat gesagt kein Bundesland sogar
annähernd überhaupt bisher ran wenn
überhaupt Schleswig-Holstein Hessen in
die Nähe aber da wird er natürlich große
Probleme haben mit seiner eigenen
Klientel zum Teil nämlich auch
Umweltschützer die sagen nein also wir
ruhen doch jetzt hier nicht bitte für
neue Windräder es gibt ein Beispiel aus
dem hessischen Reinhardswald
beispielsweise da sollen neue Windräder
aufgestellt werden schon seit einigen
Jahren es gibt massiven Protest auch von
Umweltschützern die sagen ja wir können
doch nicht einen alten Wald roden für
Windkraft also das ist hoch ambitioniert
damit Robert Habeck sich ganz schön
strecken müssen und ein bisschen ist mir
am Ende aufgefallen es wird wieder
versucht diese ganze Energiewende als
den großen Jobmotor zu verkaufen er hat
auch gesagt wir werden wieder
Innovationsland sagen ja wo hat denn
Robert habe ich die letzten Jahre gelebt
also Deutschland ist ein Innovationsland
ohne Frage aber das ist das was die
Grünen natürlich immer versuchen zu
sagen diese Energiewende die ein neuer
Innovationstreiber ist und damit
staatlich verordnet werden kann da liegt
Robert habe falsch Jobs können nicht
staatlich verordnet werden Jobs
entstehen und die ganze Energiewende hat
ja für die Industrie hohe hohe
Implikation ist alles muss finanziert
werden und was bis jetzt auch hier
fehlte war ein Preisschild was kostet
das was gibt es dann für Subventionen
für Unternehmen wie werden Jobs
künstlich am Leben gehalten oder
gefördert und am Ende die Frage ja wie
wird das alles bezahlt beispielsweise
über Steuererhöhungen dass es zum
Beispiel eine Frage unbeantwortet habe
Katja Förderung angesprochen gerade für
Industrie hat von einem osterpaket
gesprochen und auch von einem
Sommerpaket was auf den Weg gebracht
werden soll aber das Problem natürlich
mit den fehlenden Flächen ist damit
natürlich nicht gelöst ist nicht gelöst
sondern in der Debatte ist ja
beispielsweise auch eine
solardachpflicht zumindest für
neugebaute
Gewerbebetriebe da heißt es aus dem
Handwerk das ist alles schön und gut
aber wir haben gar nicht genug
Mitarbeiter zur Zeit dass es fehlen im
Handwerk ja viele viele
Mitarbeiter viele Stellen sind offen
also um auch sowas umzusetzen können bis
2030 also wir haben zum einen das
flächenproblem wir haben dann ein
Kapazitätsproblem was diejenigen angeht
die sowas installieren soll also da gibt
es der Dinge und am Ende natürlich das
Kostenproblem er hat das auf seinen
Schaubildern ganz gut dargestellt erst
dachte ich willkommen im digitalen
Zeitalter aber am Ende konnte man
tatsächlich gut sehen welche
Herausforderungen da tatsächlich noch
sind was in wenigen Jahren erreicht
werden muss Jan Schäfer vielen Dank für
die Einordnung zu diesen großen
Herausforderungen die uns da bevor